- Hi there.
I'm Seth Juarez and this is
the Microsoft Research Faculty Summit 2017,
where the theme is
The Edge of AI.
And I've got a special guest to talk
about a really interesting project.
So let's talk a little bit about the
actual problem that you're working on,
because I saw a demo of this
and I was absolutely floored
by how amazing it was.
Why don't you give us a little
background of what it is this does?
- Yeah, sure.
So first, you know,
that cancer is one of the biggest killers,
right, in the world
and the incidents
of cancer are just going up.
As people get older in the world,
more and more people get cancer eventually.
So one of the few ways to treat
cancer is radiation therapy.
And about half of cancer
patients get radiation therapy.
Radiation therapy is about using
a special purpose-built machine
that delivers
ionizing radiation
to a specific part of your body
where the tumor is,
or a patient's body
and with the intent
to kill the tumor cells
or at least to subside their growth.
And this radiation therapy,
the planning of this treatment,
is powered by medical imaging.
So what they do essentially,
they take a scan, a CT scan or
MRI scan and they need
to basically outline
every organ that there is there,
to tell the machine
what exactly needs to be treated.
And I have a little video here,
so we can look at it.
Here is a radiation oncologist planning
a treatment of a patient.
So you can see that
it's a very primitive tool.
You just draw outlines, right,
and then you switch to the next slide
and you draw another outline,
so you know,
a medical image is multiple slices
taken one after another.
And after like 300 slices,
or 200 slices, it's a very manual,
very laborious process.
And we've built a tool that helps save time,
that takes this process from between 30
and 40 minutes down to five.
- And this is interesting, right,
because when you're shooting
this radiation at the tumor,
you don't want to hit anything else,
because it's doing harm to the tumors,
you don't want to do harm
to the other things.
- Exactly, exactly.
That's why you don't only have to,
you know, delineate the tumor.
You also want to delineate
all the organs around the tumor.
And in the end, you have to delineate
like up to 20, 30 different structures in one image.
And some of the structures, like tumors,
they are different between patients,
but some of them
are the same.
So in the end, the radiation oncologist
ends up comparing hundreds of the same hip bones
that look exactly the same
between patients,
but they still have
to do that.
- And that's 40 minutes of work
for the radiation oncologist.
Is this the actual doctor that's doing this?
- Yeah, it depends on the case, right.
So brain tumors, they might take longer,
like prostate, some are simpler.
In some centers, the radiation oncologist,
a highly-paid physician is doing that.
In some centers they have people
whose job is to do this.
But yes, it's an expensive thing
to do, and usually it's physicians who do that,
instead of you know,
using the time with the patient.
- To actually treat the patient.
I mean 40 minutes of treating the patient
is a lot different
than effectively doing Photoshop
on tons of slices of a diagram
of what's inside the body, right?
- Yeah.
- So what does InnerEye actually do to help that,
and how does AI help?
- So basically our team,
there is a team of researchers in our
MSR Cambridge UK lab who worked
on computer vision
and image segmentation problems.
For many, many years they contributed
to Microsoft Kinect,
and right now we are using
the same principles
to build machine-learning
models that can actually detect,
that can actually find those body
parts for you in an image.
So this is our tool, this is the project
that we're working on,
and it looks like any other
medical imaging tool.
So you see all the standard components,
the three cardinal planes.
We have this 3-D render in here.
But this has this neat little button
that says auto-structure set
And this is something that none of the tools
in the market currently have.
And you can see that it allows you
to select what kind of image are we looking at,
and what kind of structures
are we looking at in this image?
In this case we have a computer tomography
scan of a patient with prostate cancer open here.
And when I press the start button
it kicks off the evaluation
of our machine-learning model,
which has been trained
on hundreds of images
from participating institutions
and hospitals
that we work with.
It has seen a lot of those contour tests,
and in just under a minute, probably,
here you have the pretty
accurate segmentation
of a prostate cancer case.
And this is not 100 percent correct.
So some physicians will now look
at that and say that, OK,
so I don't like how this
bladder is coming out here.
So the yellow portion
here is bladder.
So probably click the edit button
and I would kind of fix it up a little bit.
But you know, still, rather than
doing it from scratch, you're just fixing up the work.
The majority of the work,
90 percent is done by AI.
- So you've taken something that may
have taken 40 minutes to an hour down
to like maybe five or six minutes
to make sure that it's OK?
- Yeah, yeah.
This is the hope, right.
And again, you're fixing someone else's work
as opposed to like creating the same thing
over and over again.
- So this is pretty amazing.
And it looks like you're able to also map
into the 3D picture as well.
Tell us about what we're looking at here.
- Exactly.
This is 3D render,
this is another kind of product
that came out of our
MSR Cambridge Lab.
It kind of renders the data sets in three dimensions
and you can actually look at the organs
and you can see how well it scanned.
- And that's what it's actually
figured out from the pictures.
- Yeah, that's what it figured out from the pictures.
So you can see the right hip bone, for example,
here that was contoured by the automated algorithm.
If you know much about anatomy,
you see that it's pretty much accurate.
- So let's talk about the AI
that was involved in making this actually work,
because it feels a little magical.
But I want to like, we're all,
this is the faculty summit.
We're talking about research.
- Absolutely.
- How did this happen?
You mentioned a little bit about sort of the AI
that was happening at Cambridge, like the Kinect stuff.
Did some of that, was some
of that involved with this?
Because it feels like the same kind of problem.
-Yeah.
You know, so the Kinect project started way back
when, in the early 2000s, I think.
And what they have done for Kinect,
they were using machine-learning
models to solve an image segmentation problem.
- Right.
- So they were using three dimensional data.
They were using the flat image from the Kinect camera,
plus using the depth information from the depth sensor
to find body parts in the image.
To tell that this voxel in this image
probably belong to the left arm,
this is the right arm, this is the head
and these are the legs.
So in machine-learning speak,
this is a classification problem
that were on the classification
algorithm on each voxel.
So the same guys who worked on this,
and my boss Antonio Criminisi was a principal researcher on this project,
he and I contributed to Kinect.
So they took this idea further.
This idea is based on
the concept of decision trees.
The algorithm has been improved significantly.
- Sure.
- It has been tuned to fit
this particular problem
of medical image segmentation,
but the core
is kind of the same.
So you have this decision tree, and the idea
of the decision tree is that each node,
you train a very simple classifier
that tries to maximize kind of
the purity of the classes.
So all the training points,
all the voxels, get into one node
and then you try to figure out
to split them into parts
so that the voxels
that probably belong
to one kind of type
of data
goes to the left node
and another goes
to the right node.
And the process happens over and over and over,
and here down at the tree you end up
with having to split
between like a voxel
that more likely belonged
to a bladder or a voxel
to a prostate.
And at the very end, you have
very pure classes, this is how decisions...
- So when I remember, I remember
the Kinect was certainly novel
because I mean here,
I understand what decision trees are and usually I'm more about,
well what's the feature selection
that you used.
In the Kinect, they actually picked the point
that you want to predict
and picked the same set
of points around it,
not just with the actual image,
but with the actual depth data,
and those were the features.
Is it similar in this case?
- Yes.
So the feature selection process here
is somewhat similar to Kinect.
So in Kinect what they used was,
they were looking at the current voxel
and they were randomly sampling
a few points around this,
right, in a 3-D cube around this voxel.
So what we're doing here, we tried that
and we found right now I think
we're using just the full-fledged
3-D convolutions.
We're looking at all the voxels around them,
and kind of assigning weights to them,
the tree is assigning weights to them.
And we've taken this process
a little bit further.
So as opposed to doing this just based
on the voxels around the current voxel,
we also used cascades of decision trees.
And in reality, the decision forest, many to one,
but the output of one forest serves
as an input into another forest.
So the forest downstream looks at the voxels,
you know, the voxel intensities,
but also looks at the predictions
from the previous forest.
So it knows that, you know, this voxel to the left
is something that looks like a right femur,
to the right is something
that looks like a left femur.
And so probably this voxel
is more likely to be a bladder,
because it's between something
that looks like hips.
- So let's talk about this,
because this feels very similar to maybe something
that would happen in
a neural network but more treelike.
Is it similar, different?
- Yeah, you can say so.
So you know, these days everybody
talks about deep learning, right?
So what deep learning really is,
you bring multiple layers of network
and layers can do different things a little bit,
but you use the output of one layer
as an input into another layer.
And in the end you end up with kind
of a layer that is something,
uses high level features as an input,
input tree, right?
Like at the beginning you might have been
looking at just pixel voxel intensities,
and the layers further to the end
you're looking at high-level things
like a nose,
you know,
if you're trying to classify
a human face like nose,
ears, eyes, things like that.
So something similar is happening here, we're
just not using neural nets, we're using decision trees.
- But they're nested.
- There's multiple.
Yeah, they're like cascades
of those decision forests.
- So let's talk a little bit
about this program that you've built.
Is this, did you use the word tomography,
did I get that right?
Is it a tomography-type program?
- So tomography is a method of imaging the human body.
- Right.
- So there are like machines
that use certain physical kind of phenomena
to get an imaging
of the human internals.
There are several
kinds of tomography.
There is computer tomography,
there's some medical resonance tomography.
So our algorithm right now for the prostate
scans works on computer tomography,
but really kind of the underlying
technique can work on any kind of image.
- See, and that was the question because
what I was leading to is,
tell me about the dataset that you use
in order to train this effectively?
Because I'm assuming that,
what was the size of your dataset, for example?
And then, what kind of data?
Because it looks like
we focused on prostate cancer.
Will this work to extrapolate other organs
inside of the body?
- Yes.
So actually working
with the dataset ended up being more challenging
and much more interesting
than we thought it would be,
because there is so much variation
in how prostate cancer
patients are imaged
between different institutions.
You don't think, you know,
just take a computer tomography,
everyone looks like kind of
the same and go for it.
Well no.
So one institution likes to image patients
with contrast inside their bladder;
another institution would implant
something in there.
Somebody else will do some
additional contraptions that would,
you know, that would fixate
the patient in one place.
So a lot of effort went into generalizing
between the different ways,
how different institutions
kind of image their patients.
But the underlying technique,
like I said, it's a classification problem
that looks at the individual voxels.
It doesn't really care whether it's
a computer tomography or a medical resonance tomography
or whether it's a functional
MRI or a PET scan.
So it will work with any kind of 3-D
image data and moreover, so that's one of the benefits.
One of the reasons why are
using decision trees as opposed to like neural nets,
it can use multiple input layers.
Because like for brain
cancer patients, they usually take different kinds of
MR scans with different settings.
Like there's T-1 gab with contrast injection,
then there is a flair that looks at,
and they are looking
at different aspects,
the different clinical
characteristics of the tumor.
And usually a physician looks
at multiple of those scans.
So this kind of algorithm
can use multiple channels, actually.
It can look at multiple kinds of images
and it can kind of predict based on that.
But what's interesting is if you,
for example, trained it to look on three kinds of
MR scans but you only have one
at the time of scan,
it would still work because of the kind
of nature of these.
- So were you using the three
different kinds of scans?
And the reason why I'm asking is because this is
super interesting in terms of the data
you were using
and the algorithms you are using.
Were you using all three
of the scans to do the training?
But because it had all three scans,
it inferred well enough to be able
to just use one of them?
- Yes.
Because of the decision tree, right?
If you don't have, and just for clarity,
so what I just showed, the prostate case,
we only used one type of scan,
we don't use the multi-layer,
but this is something
that has been done in the research.
But theoretically, yeah.
This technique, if you trained it on three layers,
like three types of MRI, but you only have one,
it'll just use the part of the three
that you know that has to do
with this one MRI.
- I see.
- So the other branches of the tree just won't be used,
voxels won't go there.
- What if you have one of these kinds of scans,
and you don't, for example,
because it looks like you had
a specific prostate set.
You might have a set of other sets.
What if you just want to go in and color?
Because I remember, like in Photoshop
there is this like magic wand tool
to like select the right area.
Is there a way to do that
with this program as well?
Do you get what I'm asking?
- Yeah, yeah.
So this program, we wanted to build this program,
we didn't want to build, you know,
an abstract kind of research tool
that only does one thing well,
which is not practical at all.
We wanted to build something practical,
and we built in a lot of more conventional tools
that people would use.
And I can show you here, like a quick demo.
For example, this is a patient, this a different
patient, so this is not a prostate scan anymore.
This is a scan of the thorax,
of your chest parts and this is a patient,
this patient has been injected
with contrast dye,
so you can see this kind of huge
white spot in the middle.
This is the aorta
with a contrast injected in it.
And let me try to contour the aorta here,
so you can see I'm using kind of
a very natural tool, this pen.
And then I draw a contour
around this slice.
And normally the radiation oncologist
would switch to the next slice.
- For every slice he would have to draw.
- Yeah, for every slice.
So I won't do that.
I will just skip through,
skip over a few hundred slices
and go to the point
where the aorta splits.
So you can see the two white spots here,
but trust me, this is the place
where the aorta splits into left
and right femoral arteries.
So let me draw the contour around those.
All right.
And you can see that right now,
the algorithm had run an interpolation,
our interpolation algorithm has run
and it has contoured the aorta.
You can see it's not like 100 percent precise,
it captured some of the vertebrae here.
So I can click there, all right,
and I can again use my pen to fix this slice up.
And I'll just delete all this vertebrae artifacts,
and probably part of the kidney that it grabbed here.
And just now, the algorithm was again
developed in our Cambridge lab,
is trying the interpolation
in three dimensions
across what like
208 slices here.
And we have a pretty accurate segmentation
of the main blood vessel in this patient.
So we have tools like that,
which allow the physicians
to do the entire
contouring work flow within a tool.
- And that's quite remarkable,
because there may be a situation
where there is a type of cancer
that hasn't been trained on,
where you can go ahead
and do this kind of technique
inside of these scans.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And in the end, right,
we don't say that this technology
is supposed to replace kind of the radiation oncologist
and do all their jobs.
- Just a fast start.
- Yeah, it's a fast start.
And in many cases they would want
to contour more things, you know.
Or here we have the seven organs,
like bladder, femurs, prostate.
But probably they will contour
another like five or 10.
They would want to do several kind
of subtle volumes around the tumor itself,
because they want to treat a little bit
of a larger region than the tumor.
And the actual tumor they might want
to contour like in a portion of the liver
that gets into there
or something like that.
- And this is using the same machine learning techniques
from before, but to do extrapolation.
Is that right?
- No.
What I was just talking about
is they will use the simpler tools like the ones
that I've shown you now,
to do some of this interpolation
to contour the organs
that machine learning had not seen.
- I see, I see.
- Right, so the algorithm that we use,
technically it's not machine learning.
- Yeah, it feels like it would be like
a search of some kind.
- Actually it is solving the memorization problem.
So in a sense, it is machine learning,
but it runs locally.
There is not like string test phase.
- I see.
- It just optimizes kind of the path between.
- And I mean, it's pretty amazing
because now you're taking someone
that's having obviously
a very bad time there, they have cancer,
and you're minimizing the amount of useless work
that a trained physician or someone
in the medical community has to do,
and they could focus now
on the care of the actual patient.
- Yeah, exactly.
This is the promise here, because we believe,
we call this Assistive AI,
as opposed to, you know,
AI that's kind of
replacing a radiologist.
Because right now, there is this kind of buzz in this,
especially in the medical community that AI is coming,
it's going to replace a radiologist,
radiologists will go out of a job.
So people are really apprehensive, you know.
They are scared of this advent of AI,
and we think that it doesn't have to be like that,
because first, humans are
pretty good at diagnosing.
So right now there are a lot of start-ups
and a lot of companies out there working
on developing an AI
that will kind of diagnose cancer
based on medical imaging.
Well it might be useful, but really,
you know an experienced radiologist
will diagnose cancer based on the medical
imaging in a few seconds.
They don't need to really have AI for that.
- So this is amazing stuff.
Just to finish up, what's next for Project InnerEye?
- There are plenty of things that this
kind of technology can unlock.
There is this whole field
of quantitative radiology.
And surprisingly, this whole kind of medical
imaging area has been under-served by AI.
There aren't really good tools
that help physicians become better
and help them
spend more time with patients.
So you know, you can track
tumor progression over time.
You can do things like adaptive radiation therapy,
where an AI system would actually look at
how a tumor responds to the radiation treatment
in real time between sessions,
and would adjust the treatment
based on that.
Because right now, they build one plan,
the one that I've shown you, and they use that plan,
pretty much unchanged through
multiple sessions of therapy, right.
And the tumor obviously changes.
So you know, a lot of things
that we can do to improve the outcomes.
- So this is amazing stuff.
And the thing I like about it most
is that we can do a lot with computer vision.
We can match images and we can sort images, you know?
This is probably one of the best applications
of computer vision that I've seen,
because I mean, it goes to the heart
of our humanity in curing cancer.
Thanks so much for spending
some time with us, Ivan.
- Thanks for having me.
- Thanks so much for watching.
We will see you next time. Take care.